State Police say they're increasing
Patrol throughout the weekend they're
specifically targeting a portion of the
I-15 California drivers first encounter
when they drive in but the department
say police they've been struggling for
Staffing for many many years so when you
talk about moving resources down there
what does that mean for the rest of the
valley
gobble gobble holiday traffic's here I'm
over here all these pumps and stuff that
were all packed an estimated 45
000 Vehicles travel between Los Angeles
and Las Vegas every day Thanksgiving
week thousands more are expected daily
Jesus urano and Angel Madrid's work at a
gas station just over 20 miles from the
strip directly next to the 15. accidents
it gets backed all the way back there
that specifically where extra Nevada
state troopers will be positioned
starting Wednesday a partnership with
California Highway Patrol targeting a
stretch of the I-15 once considered the
deadliest stretch of highway in the
country from the prim area to St Rose
Parkway an extra 15 Nevada's Troopers
will be patrolling even if we were fully
staffed we cannot be everywhere at all
times but officer Ashley Wellman with
Nevada State Police acknowledging the
lack of troopers on state roads a full
staff of 120 not even half that the
extra Troopers this weekend coming in on
their off days through a state Traffic
Safety Grant what she says should calm
fears that there won't be enough Patrol
for the rest of the valley our Troopers
that are patrolling The Valley in our
city will be out there handling calls
for service and educating the motoring
public on traffic safety just as they
normally would
now some more steps they're taking more
messaging on electronic signs even
patrolling those driving speeds from the
sky now this portion of I-15 we're
talking about it's a zero tolerance Zone
that means even the slightest of
infractions could be enforced upon
reporting live over the I-15 on Desert
Inn by Matthew 8 news now Ryan thank you
and when Ryan reached out to the union
that represents these Troopers a
representative confirmed they're willing
to come in for the overtime they also
urge the public use more caution like
packing more food water and Medicine in
case of an accident stopping traffic